hey guys daniel rossen from the score
esports here and as you can tell I'm a
TiVo now peebo isn't just about the sick
comebacks and the crazy combos it's also
about having fun and playing fighting
games with your friends now we have a
whole video coming out dedicated to the
best plays from this year's tournaments
but for now we want to focus on the
moments that made us laugh so here are
our favorite out of game moments from
evo 2019
here guys again welcome think of it
joining us at evil 2019 it's d1 and CK
breezy yeah again it's been like months
since we ever got a chance to work
together but now we're here I'm happy I
am happy
alright anyway I think it's time for me
to go get a snack get up stretch my feet
have a nice little break here at the
jump-off it's been a pleasure hopefully
we can share is so hot that I almost
died when I got all out of it let me
come back up the steps hold on there you
go hopefully you've been enjoying
evolution mm I can't we almost died look
shares way to I bet the day alright here
we go that was sick mate day me no no
okay oh oh he said don't say you don't
get the hands know what's right now
after what you were doing doggy games in
their hands in the game you don't get
their hands on the game
[Music]
too far away Ross Seeger Ross switch
camera thank you
I was about to say if you didn't
represent this man I don't know what
looking good look at the cosplay my
goodness I love it
- noodles the noodles sleeves it ain't a
thing without the noodle sleeves true
self
oh and we got no the presidential seal
of approval
nice work guys cool that's my president
right there and we went for the
autofocus to take you here we go we go
walk into focus yeah all right he's
about that's definitely Dan slip back
there okay oh he's up is he playing is
he playing or is he just uh
man he's playin you sleep these burning
incense I wonder what character he's
gonna thank me you caught me right at it
all right easy up everybody up all right
a showman okay
shots are the guys working the street
man they be ma sorry gage okay it's not
throwing up Roy doesn't count now that
you don't get VJs for that he needs that
I can see right his mouth that was those
balls those matches so we have oh my god
is that sell that's a full sale cosplay
yo that is actually perfect so it was
funny how you sit down with cuts to him
and he would just sit down and we take a
look at the crap it's quite confident in
his speed
well I know who I wanted my squad of the
post but we got paper brackets to
hopefully I still know how to use all
the old-school tech right
actually yeah I just spit some bars oh
you'll see you'll see users do another
Oh
it's Lord I knew they were they were
gonna bring this man up I need I didn't
give him a sticker I need to give him a
sticker but this is the hero wait the
hero the Guitar Hero there you go see
Satan would be proud of a clever Yaga
way of putting the up there's but there
it is hold that that counter a little
longer too so that is that's it yeah man
it looks like I don't see anybody
shaking pants
yeah good games stuff is good games
though like it's probably the first time
okay but he would have gone for the
spike I mean I think he wasn't a
position to really try to spike the Rob
made Josh playing however really smart
just pushes himself away and even with
the answer oh man look the tears coming
it oh and here we go we got the hi hey
go sir that is so many gasm this guy is
hype he said you know what that's it he
loves anime man hey he loves his anime
to get to the wall doing little dance I
don't know what that was man rebellion
spear to finish the job yes Buffalo and
the glass push up he isn't full anime
form I can only imagine how dissing
horny has to be on their side but that's
dissing Hartington watch help yeah he
brought his whole thing oh man
my guns he's jumping into him
unfortunately and Jim Bailey just caught
on to that place super patient literally
just waited le CC to just land for the
most part it was like re having you
burned your second don't you have
nowhere else to go I'm glad I'm glad the
camera didn't get to focus Bailey what
the hell is this let's go to keep our
damn pad so he's using the pad to sink I
guess to the the PlayStation adding it
and then he's gonna play on the keyboard
and then that is I know that character
that's hasta la food
ask-ask the raw food I don't know how to
say it I stole all food that is his
waifu all right we're getting ready to
get some more matches my name is eros
this is Marc man he's been attentive
every match has not been playing
overwatch at all during the mattress hey
where'd you get that
Oh see those I'm finna get turned so who
is now paying attention I was watching
the math I was watching the I'll let it
slide this time no big deal Wow
at least they're sharing even ground
here going into the match alright you
want candy joke's on you bro yo watch
boxing that bad baby is a lunchbox and
that's what happens you can't clean your
trunk bro you got it you got to take
some of that out be extremely difficult
challenge kids take down coach you can
see the book oh we've got the book right
speed right a dispute early he's reading
all the the post spirit promotion setups
okay yes there's that many of them right
yeah left-right up-down Center it's it's
a destined to ruin movies girl hold the
students from South Korea
takes it he's like yeah yeah idea says
one more I'm just gonna go up against
kyani so hold on to that
make sure base has the energy a look at
this wait thought he's like qiyamah you
need my limiters on first like you only
could it this game Tommy I'm good at
four different games and Here I am on
the cut up getting a bit does even not
even a hometown favorite necessarily
just a whole crowd clapping crowd
cheering clapping getting getting some
of those wrestling not those arresting
claps in right because he's into it
kind of curious which who wants to be on
what side right now though I don't know
who's looking for what they can't even
get the rules right the other that's the
other mind game rock-paper-scissors
someone gonna be on where to count and
maybe that's actually part of my game
but it looks like we do have a change
here yeah Kalin Ramos is now gonna be
moving to what I assume is a 2 player
side and not falling hopefully we're
good we're good we're cool I swear work
with cool people my favorite cartoons
Netflix cartoon yeah what's your netflix
high school does that mean anime
forgotten what's on Netflix is in
English both that's not anime what's
animated prints the cartoon wears it
made this Netflix as I presume is
displayed in America they go don't be
fooled by all the trolls and life
already be in English and on Netflix if
it was an anime like no one's naked in
it it's good a wholesome fun I'd never
watch that stuff that you degenerate
rubbish how dare you accuse me of it
anyway they're high school girl
[Applause]
just going straight powders inject the
other rub Mooney straight into my veins
right now what is the legality on that
it's gotta be you started get a new
sponsor man 38 years old
this man looks like he's 22 tops
what at 22 22 I wouldn't give you no
more than thankful at my hands do it
well see well not all of us are lucky
you see Logan
I don't know mine I go cool - I'll go
food for those shoulders echoquote red I
thought perhaps I'd definitely go bald
fabs but anyway I think we have to break
owed it goes
crunches behind the stage he's so
unknown he's not even listed on that
slide over there
[Applause]
young man from China GC oh yeah the last
time I see somebody from Scotland out
here but I'm not surprised especially at
evolution Wow okay why preach paper
paper beats Rock I'm not too sure here
mixers coming off a loss oh don't show
that on evil man's 80,000 people just
saw the off word hate oh my come on iris
is already doing a video on it their
player the way that was actually the
tournament that got under night on my
radar
yeah the spread was so hype yeah and the
crowd was so excited yeah unfortunate
but it's hard to block what do you do
because anyway you don't really like
this we're definitely about the story I
feel like now this is your car we found
the connection right there's the
handshake that's a you know
and chicken didn't leak any information
right because because we have no
information to announce I'm sorry I'm
sorry okay enjoy about thank you that's
all
all cause ups getting dusky head of him
a be a liar
you don't think peaches ready for Qualls
like that dealing with Bowser all day I
don't know yeah I guess she's not gonna
swipe that much she's just getting
picked up like rats
I don't know what they do back at the
castle but either way all right now it's
time for some of our favorite fails and
funny moments that happen to in game at
this year's Evo when you can recover
come around like that and I'd come up
there in the Scramble but was she quite
morale boost oh yeah and now unsafe but
they punish those really matters
oh there's the share button that's a
weird one that is definitely different
so one of the two fighters press the
share button yeah at the power crutch
available right no it's not an obvious
deal with the toys I connected alone
here hamish no full life bleep gentleman
come up oh my goodness what is going on
here oh my goodness he has crashed the
game combos - oh hey he did change this
tag and he keep doing this side B so I
don't know that's all the player has the
profile I keep my action to be trying to
snipe with you
I'm gonna tell you right now that this
sir play is like that man
wait you think they hop in please pad
for this and all they do is go special
but I'm doing a really good job keeping
the pressure on opps no for the normal
upbeat guess all the first time or no
you didn't just do the jebaited face to
Bailey obviously the debated comma right
there just stand on stage do nothing it
to let them as because know if you
really buy too much oh okay obviously
the crushing blow dropkick haven't seen
that in a while
commits into the Lok at the last second
that is somewhat of a mix-up there is
one of the harder situations to funny
wake up fatal blow but remember fatal
blows only have armor from the fifth
frame onwards that's that's exactly what
it means and he was going for underwater
top thing to do
tried to get a lot of momentum around
Sarabhai to a [__] and with the figures
monster was already on it now he's and
now we're gonna vote with these guys two
socks apiece and you could see [__] of
pretty much dancing and who so finally
able to actually go and enough snapshot
a shield to get that pressure off of so
many of those two days yeah and thinking
I don't know what spooked you go was
trying to read there with a char shot he
just wasted but Peng Diaz light will go
back to stage gladly oh no Joe which one
is he going to get and a goodbye Nana
yeah not really much you can do there on
recovery against the Nikki to like that
end he takes it so - just to make this
even once again okay thanks can I see
you capitalizes off of that and red now
a full stock ahead with 50% to spare and
he is not like beets he'll get anything
on time looking for them
oh no accidents and Vicki getting the
edge guards but I you know may also
tossing out those grenades know the
earth so that's a big miss do it again
do it again and you guys can't see this
with a bronson Trent as soon as it got
hit with that drag until he started
laughing because I think running black
told sweet she likes the headed one more
drag there's no office state to freak
that and high five run it black I don't
know what's going on to their you now
the good thing though is now he's gassed
he had to sprint all the way over to run
it black and now it's about you know
really I know somebody's control who
disconnected Oh controllers disconnect
know what's going to tell me that did
not
this guy did I think that he thought it
was all wrong no I just went along with
it how mess up so badly broke these guys
unplug their sticks are you kidding me
right now come on don't these guys
deserve to lose I cannot stand you might
be able to leave getting the fight with
tweek is rolling ok the bike finally
knocking squeak out of his momentum but
he's not that he has not returned
anybody misses the oh my god it's like
we came on that one he wasn't like I
have an opportunity to kill you but I
won't just like its challenged by
buttons this is what Laura does a little
bit of nerves maybe from item functional
under pressure using that experience
here weather the storm
you can't gray help forever in this
season it is not possible
here's the pressure is just Larry but
knew that the correct counter early in
play for pucci below who knows these
setups that's a huge part of it yeah
talking for about that you dilute
observe orient decide so what all that
friendliness awake
we're not playing friendlies not these
are seriously last time I checked man he
came to miss that fist bump to I don't
do that no yeah we don't do that bad I
do not like the mid 7s model that's
another way to disarm you dude
yeah hey man good game come on let's go
let's go not just with the beacon
missile or three he just goes for it no
no wait what what does he think he's
winning based off life he did okay god
that was really scary
[Applause]
he was just like wait you thought you
one day and I guess they're just like
yeah I don't have to do anything
yep I am is really good Oh Ricky is not
even a turd pretties like look at his
screen like oh there's someone else here
alright guys those are all our favourite
fails and funny moments from Evo 2019 I
hope you enjoyed the video and don't
forget to Like subscribe and comment and
hopefully I'll see you here next year
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]